j'aurai terminé avec sarah qui étaient
avant la co-vedette soignante à
l'hôpital public en service cardio et
peut-être que vous que vous nous disait
quel a été votre expérience de la voilà
de la première vague de l'épidémie quand
vous étiez à l'hôpital public comment ça
se passait comment vous l'avez vécu
bonjour et merci déjà de permettre de
m'exprimer vous en prie déjà j'ai été
volontaire moi-même pour y aller dès le
23 mars dès la première vague quand j'ai
eu mon entretien d'embauché
tout de suite ça va aller vous verrez
vous allez est en sécurité on vous
protège première chose on nous a envoyé
quatre fois des faux négatifs
donc en fait je comprenais uns que les
autres que les urgences étaient engorgés
qu'il fallait aller très très vite
d'accord mais fallait être certain des
patients qu'on envoyait d'autant plus
que la cardiologie ne faisait pas partie
des services reconditionné au service
qu'au vide donc quatre patients comme ça
on nous a dit vous inquiétez pas ils
sont négatifs et en fait il était
positif des collègues ont été contaminés
des collègues l'ont ramené à leurs
enfants
bon bizarrement pour deux d'entre elles
qui étaient pour un cdi elles se sont
fait licencier bizarrement ensuite plus
de matériel il y avait vraiment plus
rien enfin un exemple pour aller prendre
une tension à un patient fallait prendre
2 tensiomètres 1 pour la tension le
deuxième il vous prenait la saturation
mais tout ça c'était normal il fallait
pas s'inquiéter au bout d'un moment il y
avait plus du tout de matériel on a
leash et déco vide avec des masques
chirurgicaux et quand on avait la chance
d'avoir des ff [ __ ] il était périmé depuis
2010 est on en n'est pas ce qu'on fait
non mais franchement pour un hôpital
public j'ai trouvé ça honteux parce que
à l'inversé une fois que l'on m'a dit à
la fin de la première vague qu'on a été
d confiné qu'on m'a dit ça rend vous
trouvez un petit peu trop à l'aise donc
on va pas vous garder
d'ailleurs c'est la première fois de ma
vie qu'on fait ce coup là c'est pas
grave tant pis je vais changer je vais
aller dans le privé
et c'est dommage que la ministre soit
partie parce que j'avais cette question
comment se fait-il que dans le privé où
ils ont quand même beaucoup en aide de
l'état
il arrive actuellement là où je suis à
nous protéger
alors là où vous êtes certains foyers
pour handicapés ont procédé à tout à
fait sur evreux qui est vraiment très
bien c
première fois que je me sens autant
protégé ses limites si pour aller
déplacer à déposer pardon à plateaux
repas on met pas la combinaison de
spationaute entièrement comment un
établissement privé peut avoir les
moyens de tout ça pour nous et en plus
on est testé pcr tous les mois il y en a
eu en moi quand je suis arrivé chez eux
septembre là il y en a encore un mais
pas que nous tous nos résidents aussi
quand ils rentrent de chez leur famille
ils sont confinés sept jours dans leurs
champs ils vont penser que ça correspond
à la situation générale qu'il ya une
différence telle entre toutes privées
tout le public
non mais on paie clairement je pense que
le public veut faire des économies alors
que dans le privé c'est pas du tout
pareil là c'est un lieu de vie déjà
c'est pas un hôpital et c'est comme une
grosse famille donc ils font très très
attention alors à à leurs résidents
c'est pas du tout la même chose déjà à
l'hôpital on vous dit pas vous avez des
patients vous allez voir tel client
on les appelle des clients des gens les
appels plus des patients ça aussi c'est
honteux et à tous ce problème aussi
autour de oui c'est vrai nous les aides
soignantes et je voulais aussi mettre
l'accent sur les amp pour ceux qui
connaissent passer des aides médico
psychologiques qui font notre métier
mais elles sont toute la partie psy en
plus donc elles sont encore plus
patiente que nous et elle elle ne
bénéficie pas de prime elle ne bénéficie
pas d'augmentation de salaire d'ailleurs
celle-ci moi je n'ai pas vu il ya eu
trop d'inégalités aussi en fait et eux
ils n'ont pas les moyens il arrive à
nous protéger et pas un hôpital public
et je voulais savoir pourquoi
où part l'argent des hôpitaux publics en
fait or il fera encore loin de passer la
question mais vous qui êtes à
l'intérieur du système
quelle est votre position sur un
possible assouplissement du
déconfinement par exemple est ce que
vous y être favorables toujours
intéressant d'avoir l'avis de quelqu'un
qui au plus près des réalités pour les
leur foyer de vie oui il faut parce que
on a affaire là des résidents donc comme
vous avez compris tous un fauteuil
roulant ou leur seul plaisir de base
c'était d'aller voir leur famille il y
en a qui ne peuvent pas du tout parce
que c'est trop loin et qu'il n'y a pas
là et les distances de kilomètres pour y
aller mais sont pratiquement quasiment
tous en dépression la la semaine
dernière malheureusement j'ai un
résident qui s'est enroulé sa sonnette
autour du cou heureusement que les
filles sont arrivées à temps
c'est le droit de sortir et leur seul
plaisir en plus c'est vrai c'est la
nourriture et ils ont même pas le droit
d'aller s'acheter leur paquet de
chocolats leurs paquets de bonbons c'est
le seul plaisir qu'ils aient et on les
laisse pas faire parce qu'ils sont
personnes fragiles oui d'accord mais
c'est leur seul plaisir donc des
assouplissements très localisées
notamment pour l'établissement enfin le
genre d'établissement dans lequel vous
travaillez
oui pour nous résidents oui à propos de
ça je pense que c'est important de noter
qu'il existe aujourd'hui des tests
antigénique pour lequel vous en 20
minutes vous avez une résultat en 20
minutes
or en fait il s'est développé une sorte
de marché du test pcr que les
laboratoires facture 49 euros alors que
dans d'autres pays c'est moins cher et
elle surtout alors que ce test un petit
génique est beaucoup moins cher qu'on
peut le faire chez soi
enfin franchement on pourrait
généraliser de façon beaucoup plus forte
sa distribution de tests antigénique et
pour ce type de situation par exemple
pour vous risquez vous pourriez faire
systématiquement avant un projet de
sortie un test antigénique non seulement
pour le résident et y compris pour toute
la famille qui est amené à le faire et
on peut recommencer la semaine d'après
et la semaine d'après et la semaine
d'après et ça on dirait que on est on
est prêt à mettre des millions pour des
labos qui sont par ailleurs aussi dans
un état de profiteurs de guerre un peu
profiteurs de crise comme les
hypermarchés mais on fait pas ce qu'il
faut pour faire bénéficier tous le monde
des avancées scientifiques qui ont déjà
de 6 mars ce sera ma dernière question
quelle est la politique de test pour le
personnel des foyers comme comme celui
dans lequel vous travaillez là la
politique des tests est ce que vous êtes
tester régulièrement et c'est efficace
mais semblent tous les mois moi là ça
fait deux mois que j'y suis et ben y en
a eu 1 le mois dernier l'aïe en a encore
eu ans on a les résultats nous sous 48
heures voilà donc en fait on avait trahi
il avait travaillé avec de la boue on
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait un la beauce
a demandé deux trois semaines il y en
avait un autre 48 heures forcément n'a
gardé celui à 48 heures et les résidents
ils y sont favorables
ils ont mal nous le 10 mai
ils y sont très favorables justement à
ça parce qu'ils savent que du coup ils
sont protégés ils sont certains qu'on
leur ramène rien que nous on n'a rien
attrapé non plus et nous ça nous permet
aussi de se sentir en sécurité et de
rien ramener à la maison
je me suis séparé de ma fille au premier
confinement pour la mettre en sécurité
j'ai pas encore envie d'être éloigné
d'elle